[Music]
for days now
all the women on my staff have been
freaking out because this
movie is coming out called magic mike
xxl
i don't know much about the film uh just
judging by the title
i'm assuming it's about a very heavy
magician
i don't know they said they were going
to go to a midnight showing
i said i want a girl's night out can i
come with you they said yes
and i rented a limo and i think we're
going to have a good time i want to find
out what this
is all about so let's get my magic mike
xxl
own this is my assistant sona's
apartment
all the ladies are meeting there this is
like an episode of cops
and instead of arresting murderers i'm
just hanging out with some women and
going and seeing a movie
hey sona hi how are you
what okay that was my assistant
showing no affection how many years have
i you worked for me
uh a little over six years no affection
i did this
what's going on you already did it
though okay we're good
all right who's excited for magic mike
xxl tonight
i haven't seen you ladies react this way
to a movie franchise before you didn't
do this for ninja turtles
what's going on you can tell the
difference between a really good dancer
and thank you excuse me right right you
can tell the difference between
a real between a real man and a guy
who's just pretending to be
a man who isn't a real man is that what
you're saying is that what you're saying
you know what this is called the sea
tatum you know why
this is what channing tatum drinks i
happen to know because i'm friends with
ct
did you know that we're friends no with
cheite
that's yeah
and i told you that i know him a bit
i've met him he's been on the show i
don't think
you like know him as well as you think
you do i he's been on the show
he has been on the show but that doesn't
mean you like know him i know him well
enough to know that he doesn't look like
this in real life
you like him a lot i love would you
marry him
if you could marry him i would marry him
so hard and quickly you don't marry
someone hard
i would
[Laughter]
like a masculine tarzan kind of guy
i don't know i feel like they appeal he
looks like a lumberjack that's off his
meds
he really does he looks like he's
pointing to a tree that he forgot to
fell
and he's gone crazy what do you think
what do you what do you do does this guy
do it for you
what's different between this guy
and me i think he might have
a little bit of a tan
are you excited about tonight uh yeah
are you going to scream and go whoo
where does the women go they go like
is that what you do i might do a woo if
everyone else is doing
you know we know someone
raise your hand tonight if you would
like it if you saw a penis be honest
would you like to see one with it
okay okay let me tell you something
again
this is a fallacy i hate to break it to
you it is a scientific fact that men
with this upper body have a very small
that was supposed to be for like every
pound you lose
you gain a niche what are you talking
about are you saying
are you saying jared from subway has a
36-inch
every time
so that these men that lose 600 pounds
who were trapped in their home
are walking around with a freaking fire
hose
no these are the fallacies what kind of
dance moves are we going to see can
anyone show me what who here is a good
dancer who could show me basically what
we're going to see tonight take their
uh pelvic region and then they just
pound it to the ground up and down
what's the point of that
it's uh simulating uh
sexual intercourse with the floor okay
i'm gonna play some music and i'm gonna
do what feels natural
[Applause]
is
how about this
[Applause]
to leave my body exposed if i'm hexeled
out right now
that would be because they thought it
didn't look good how do you ladies like
the limo huh
yeah nice and look what i brought
champagne
[Music]
let's talk about the myth of penis and
size now
i have it on good authority that women
don't care for a large penis it can be
bothersome
you can actually hear the air
conditioning
logic
yay what are we drinking what would you
ladies like we have fun shots called
booty juice whatever you want
what is your name leah leah very nice to
meet you nice to meet you
we're gonna go see magic mike xxl are
you jealous
yeah you know i really want to buy you a
booty juice well thank you i appreciate
that
that's the second time this week i've
said that yeah first time to a woman
all right can you come with us tonight
maybe i have to call myself yes don't
you no no no no no what if what if your
boss is
i would like eight tickets for magic
mike xxl
okay that is seven female tickets
and one man ticket
no one would magic
[Applause]
the child just is being taken away
quickly
this is getting really exciting now we
are eight minutes
away from magic mike xxl starting and i
am ready
i am lubricated ovulating
i am more woman than i've ever been
before and i'm ready to be taken
on the ride of my life i'm ready to have
a baby
a baby with a movie
i don't know what's happening wow
that was great that was really fun bye
guys
bye ladies bye-bye
i'm tired it's been a long day just
gonna turn
in
good night
man you were really good in the movie
you really did too
i wasn't in the movie joe
joe
no sex tonight
thank the ladies for letting me crash
and thanks to joe manganello for getting
into bed with me uh